test audio dite qualcosa labbra per la
bla bla bla non è vero non servivano tre
storie che ho fatto parlar basse per i
ragazzi che mi ha visto un video sono
qui oggi siamo con i super man consola
anche resistente bene anche dentisti
stefano e veronica anche detti amici di
falli james dicendo cagate ragazzi gradi
su scribi punto io che è questo gioco
fantastico dove tutti i segni le cose e
gli altri devono indovinare che cosa
bisogna siccome siamo tutti e dei
picasso mancati e video bellissimo da
fare la scalata forse non mi ricordo ma
scusami e italia e gli italiani inglesi
e italiane italiano e l'italiano va bene
per eva il bello è una rovina e poi non
puoi impossibile no non ci crede morta
comunque è un talento naturale piuttosto
gioco ma cos'era e un imballi amo la
verità su cosa si deve focalizzare così
ci arriva e la questa la formula forse
esatto primi tre hanno nella pur china
perché quelle per i capelli
a un'altra attivo dai gol graffetta
tirarmela dopo in una lettera sola mi dà
la scusa migliore una sola me l'ha messa
come io ero li ha fatti pensavo che le
stesse dando di più da una mi serve
inutilmente capirla graffetta allora
sono pronto
vediamo allora ecco lavoro e sici pizza
96 no adesso si capisce ma un aereoplano
è vicino all'aeroplano scrivere ho
scritto aeroplano che abbiamo il mal
d'aria
queste sei è cortissima è cortissima se
il colore è scelto di proposito che è
bello davvero
è un piede veramente supporto gravissimo
no questo è possibile
ci provo calcio di punizione
e questa è la più semplice e pensate che
una era a china può averlo capito tutto
ho capito che cosa può essere bravo
capito che senso la cina cos'è vedo
neanche avara di fosse fantasia
disegnano e poi fiutano prezzi campo da
qualcosa non l'ha capita che cade
parapetti sono 22 persone che volevano
venire allora arca vita ma come pensi a
queste cose
lei però punizione io ho scritto il
tavolo da gioco michel gioco da tavolo
ma dai tavolo da gioco è perché tu
cerchi su un tavolo hai bisogno ma
inizio gruppo è colpa di questo gioco
che ti fa dimenticare come ti ricordi si
parla col mali come gioca colpa del
gioco
cosa stai scrivendo a tramp ok ok
andiamo avanti presidente private questo
è un capolavoro sappiatelo ci vorrà un
sacco però ne vale la pena
ok la cosa importante è questo panzino
altri muri altri modi no non è bandito
che sembra fallito
il bandito da un posto
bobine per la maledizione ma cavolo ma
perché però pure fatto arancione avevi
capito fin da subito e brera difficile
[Musica]
che sei fantastica ma che bravo aspetta
bella la puglia prof molti non fatto che
questa volta campi mi sono capitato
tutto riveli non so chi dirà se è così
si è arrivati aspetta da datemi secondo
a scrivere se si era impegnata a sono
bellissimi e l'altro quanto tempo scrive
negato la doppia mi ferì dai
[Musica]
cos'è sta roba impegnative rho mi sto
impegnando sul mare sono
concentratissimo mi evocava la guerra la
presa che ho fatto tutto la capillarità
parma e storica è un personaggio ma non
si capisce è un personaggio storico è
qualcuno da gente le vendite per la
barba tutti alla barbarie bar costa di
mille pezzetti di tenere 1800 a chi è
barbara lvad elegante ma mi sarebbe mai
venuto meno
magritte umane anche nonna che fa bene
mamma mia ragazzi veramente difficile
prenderli quella che disegnato
l'incredibile ai qua come faccio a
essere così bravo dai dominata mi stavo
anche incartando allenata questa volta
non la dico più nostra verdi per strada
ci sembrava il cassonetto della plastica
ma il cerchio
ho pensato a quello va dai vinto macro
positive
lasciatemi fare quello che ha disegnato
peggio e vince è questione di indovinare
non disdegnava adesso lo facciamo in
polacco per go round 1 empre per ha
visto che erano in tre a pesci vendo
scusami ma manca totalmente il pesce
potrebbe essere un po troppo sofisticata
io toby soldi a bravo
ebbene la prima cosa a cavallino maschio
ma dai che lo sai anche tu no no non mi
viene in mente adesso e paypal nord ma
si batte per pensato in passato pensando
alla terza compatta marte aimo lei
allora questa difficile non parte ok no
ma mi è piaciuto nostra come ma non si
parli direttamente si è pagato un ha
scelto la tav e dobbiamo farci sospinto
telepiù dai è facile questa è una casa
ciao ho capito ho capito con telepiù
stanno palesemente leandro come facevo
barlow dai nel culpa per me così zampe
ei vecchio il primo pensa prima li si sa
non è morto
una tipo nutri all'inizio della storia
più o meno simili non lo so che non so
che rimane sia pari a un capolavoro ben
si sa assolutamente sì ma non ho capito
ho capito
brava brava quando in zona della pancia
cerchio a prestare attenzione ok però
non capisco lo stesso aspetta
ho perso il mio momento io capitando
biancofiore comparate ecco è vero fatto
bene dai
anzi meglio di prima
[Applauso]
ci stava messicana basta co sti
messicani è ok
sono segnali non ci posso fare nulla
questa volta no non comprendo la cosa
sembrava non lo so chi è e spalmate cose
musicali loro non lo capisco ma notte
va bene che le veroniche spagnoli o
amicali messicano erika gandara
facilissimo e lo so io ero troppo
difficile un libro è possibile sono un
genio grazie caffè è possibile non ce la
faccio e stato incredibile
mamma mia ecco infatti i numeri erano
veramente preso veramente presto era
vicinissima comunque da macchie rea
fernando bellissimo ai ragazzi chiedo
quale episodio di disegni a caso con
seppe bere perché vi sia piaciuto
schiacciate gli stili alla campo
dell'altra riceve notifiche cose sempre
in un prossimo fantastico video da
ragazzi
[Musica]